謝謝大家的時間
那個知不知道最近一段時間以來
從其實從瑞士這個瑞士會議以後
市場上非常有名的交易叫Tackle
Tackle stand for Trump always checkin' out
就是特朗普這家話老是會認鎖
所以那個最近的政治上的變化其實有一點多
就是你會看到其實在上週的時候
美國的法院一次ruel to Trump的Tackle
然後又讓他sustain
就讓他reinstall
就循回法院再 reinstall
所以來回搞不好幾次
但是市場對特朗普說要對中國重新加稅
或者說他有發了一個自己在去蘇修上發了一個相當於推特的東西
說那個中國好像這麼說
說中國沒有執行他們要執行的東西
so much for being a nice person
但是市場沒有很買的
大家覺得他最後就會認鎖
特朗普這個政策波動性很大
他講的東西不用太嚴肅
所以這個市場在5月份的時候其實有一幅很大的翻看
包括這個是cross equity市場
cross to rate市場
利率市場也是
就是我們看到steepener
然後看到rate往上走了很多
30年的話其實現在到5%
10年到4.5%
其實市場有兩個最大的
就從中美開始緩和
其實從liberation day
美國的解放日
大跌之後
其實市場就重新開始pricing兩件事情
第一件事情就是美國經濟增長還是還可以
有一些很多的樂觀因素
覺得美國經濟增長看上去還比較樂觀
那麼背後的原因是覺得
第一個特朗普的很多關稅政策他不太會持續
第二個就是美國會重新印不少的錢
就是我們叫physical spending
就是政府層面財政層面會開始花錢
那麼這個是帶動市場
就是說包括rate市場
rate在跌嘛
然後包括股票市場在反彈
中間很重要的兩個原因
那麼我今天講一下
我對於整個市場的一個overview
就是整個市場的感覺
然後說一下我對宏觀的一個看法
其實宏觀看法並沒有改變
我沒有那麼樂觀
但是你記得我上一周
我上周好像講的時候上上周吧
兩周前
我給一個這麼東西
其實我當時講到的就是說
我們對比2024年年初
為什麼說2024年其實是一個
2024年年底的時候
我們認為是有可能有tell risk
因為當時的position很
就是經濟增長層面
經濟增長基本面看下去很好
然後市場position非常重
就是頭吋非常單邊
然後都在壓多
然後市場情緒很好
所以我們會覺得他有一個crush
就有可能會脆斷的可能
現在的情況就從兩周前來看
市場的頭吋可能去比較輕
但是估值仍然很高
然後 fundamental不太清楚
所以我當時會覺得市場是到年底了
就是到年底的話
市場是會比較有確定性的
我覺得經濟會軟著落
那麼現在的估值過高
但是不像2024年年底
會有一波很快很急的下調
因為position頭吋
市場的頭吋比較平輕
那當時的兩星期前觀點
現在的市場
我先說一下市場position
我覺得這個大家可能關心的比較多
現在來看市場position
已經比當時要重很多了
那麼在過去一個月裡面
Global的CTA和Global
Global我們叫全球的CTA和涼化策略
那就是趨勢更中性的策略
我們一般叫做CTA加上
Resparity加速Volcan control
那這些策略
一共買了100的billion equity
100billion就1千億美元
我們看到的是在下一周
至少在下一周
甚至在下一個月
這個是一個月的數據
這個是一周的數據
那個幾乎不會有新的流量
竟然繼續買股道
就從CTA和Resparity
CTA-Resparity的Volcan control來看
基本上是一個賣出的節奏
也就是你可以簡單的
這個是Global
我這邊沒有放一個美國的
右邊是美國的
Global來看的話
美國其實也差不多
就是你股票繼續上漲
或者是持平
它就是那個CTA維持不怎麼動
但是如果發生一個Standard deviation下調
那麼它就會賣出很多
所以這個都是一個加速器
我們會看到Position並不像
兩個星期前這麼好
就是兩個星期前
我們認為Position很light很輕
然後我們認為可能固執有點高
但是問題是那個CTA當時
都還沒有大量健倉
那個重新要買入
現在我們認為CTA已經接了不少倉了
但是你不能說跟2025年的時候
2025年年頭的時候
今年年頭的時候
或去年年底的時候
那個CTA需要健倉需要買那麼多
對吧
沒有說頭寸打滿
確實沒有像那個時候那麼危險
但是你要用Position
就是市場的頭寸
然後來認為要重新有人進倉
要進場
然後使得股票繼續漲
這個邏輯不大存在了
就說現在我覺得頭寸並不是說很重
但是頭寸肯定不能支持用那個倉位
來支持市場繼續上漲
是什麼一個情況
那麼我們說到市場倉位和算牌
就是市場有人要買的話
另外一個不能不提的就是說是Equity Back
Equity Back在過去一周
過去幾天裡面也是慢慢
就是2024年的時候還是稍微少一點
但是有個Blackout Window要出來
就是公司在年報之前一般兩個星期
他們就會開始進入Blackout
結果能夠繼續買股票
那麼整個美股其實美股原來是靠風紅
後來大家都是靠回購
就是買股票回購
所以買股票回購其實是能預申
你一直有一個進滿入的量
是帶動美股就是長牛的一個很重要的原因
那麼每一次Blackout Window中間
其實對這個股價
對市場都是會有一些影響
因為缺少了這麼一個支撐的力量
那麼Blackout Window開始
大概是6月16號到7月25號左右
那麼根據不同的公司
是開始時間不太一樣
那Financial sector可能會最早
因為他們的業績是最早的
然後接著可能是Tact sector
那些公司
那麼整個Blackout Window開始
從一兩個星期之後
所以現在我們看到
已經看到Volume Decrease
就是從那個公司回購來看
它的回購量在下降
所以你從算市場的流動性
和算市場的買入量的話
不管是從CTA的Position也好
這個可能就算得口比較短期
幾個星期的還是滿
幾個星期還是挺有影響力的
從CTA的投存和Position也好
從那個byback也來説也好
市場的Position並沒有
並沒有那麼supportive
並沒有那麼支持這個股票
就是繼續這樣衝高
然後回到我們之前講的這個估值的問題
為你沒走數據吧
就講到我覺得做幾個比較
那個如果說按照今年的那個PE來說的話
S&P的PE
現在和那個Trump election的時候
大概差不多吧
按照今年的PE的話
那個可能是25倍
那麼你就是25倍
25到26倍
那麼你看今年增長多少
那麼即使今年你說
你覺得增長10%
那現在也在22倍
也是22倍
22倍多
那麼這個我們就說按照過去的PE來算的話
那麼在那個pre-pandemic的時候
那個pre-pandemic那個市場
相當於還是在一個牛市的狀態
那個時候是23倍
但是你回過來比較
當時的30年期的國債是2022
現在30年期國債是5%
所以你的risk premiums
在完全不同的兩個level上
所以你的risk premium
現在相比較當時會要高很多
你的估值比當時要高很多
然後pre-pandemic的時候
沒有覺得會衰退
因為這個衰退是一個
忽然之間被襲擊的
就這個疫情是忽然襲擊的
那麼你當時定價是經濟是很不錯
那現在其實這個很不錯
是很難定價的
也就是今年的
現在的經濟的基本面
我當我講到經濟數據和基本面
我覺得今年的基本面
軟著落的概率是幾乎是肯定的
那如果即使不衰退也要軟著落
所以從估值上來說
市場我覺得還是比較危險的
因為估值偏高
然後position不是這麼supportive
這個就是現在可能的狀態
那麼但是同樣的話
在這樣的一個情況下
這個是overall對於SNP來說
可能是沒有狀態
就是說我覺得整體估值可能是偏高的
然後不是那麼supportive
但是通過不同的公司和secret來講
那麼相比較來說
我用另外Honey other hand
我又覺得相當於科技公司
甚至四個原廠
半導體
就Name也就四個原廠和半導體
它的估值對於整個市場的
估值是偏低的
這我個人能感受
所以如果在尋求激活的話
你們就是倉位中間是需要
有一定的倉位的話
就我覺得這個市場總是
不是一個清倉的一個市場
所以你要確定有一些倉位的話
那麼這個倉位
我覺得是適合
或者半導體和那個原廠
我們看到的一些數據是這樣子
就是原廠的token utilization是非常好
就是這個是上一輪年幫我們也看到
然後現在那些原廠的反饋其實也是
就是token utilization
就是AI使用到它的芯片的使用率
其實非常好
那麼這個東西包括Meta Google
包括Amazon
包括Microsoft
然後其實Meta Google
更多是自己使用
其實多數據都是挺好
也就是說我們從過去兩年以來
整個對於AI的投資
或者AI的炒AI這輪概念
就是背後最重要的一個東西就是CAPEX
就是雲廠商的投入
那個雲廠商的投入
那麼就是取決於
有沒有人繼續去使用這個token
那確實是有
然後CAPEX的回報
我們叫ROI
CAPEX的投資回報還是很不錯
所以這個東西中間背後帶動的
就是市場在下跌的時候
是質疑了AI的概念
AI是跌得很慘
現在還沒有Recover
包括其實Recover最近的是Microsoft
Recover最近的Microsoft
現在大概30倍P
那麼相比叫我馬是50倍
而Socius相比叫Costco是50倍
所以就是這個市場的定價
其實是有些funky的一些奇怪
就是說我們說可能會
川普可能會check out
但是問題是川普一直在搞不同的推我
包括對於中國的關係
其實一直在變緊張
這個不光是那個TRADE的貿易方面
其實在軍事方面也在變緊張
那你們可以看到
比方說他們在美國國防部長
對於臺灣的這個明確的一個表態
就是第一次明確的表態
我軍事上是要支持臺灣
或者是軍事上防衛臺灣
這個是第一次
那以前Biden就是四個yes
你叫問他有會不會
我說yes會
那反正他老娘昏虧
隨便講講你就yes
但是防長第一次明確的
這樣的表態是第一次
中美關係之間
中美關係我覺得修復的概率是很低的
那麼像美國公司的估值裡面
你會看到像Microsoft可能是20倍
Navillian是22倍
那今年Navillian是22倍
那Mobal可能是20倍
這都是算今年
Mobal可能是在20倍
所以我們會看到相比較而言
盈利更加有確定性
因為Kapax的確定性很高
就是我們叫次大兵場投入
Kapax的確定性很高
那麼在有確定性投入更高的這些
收益收入的確定性也更高的公司
相反Ai的這些公司
相反它的PE相對來說更低一點
所以Vinsat就是整個S&P
我們說overall的估值
我覺得是很高的
那這中間包括financial set
包括retail set
這兩個方面我都覺得都挺高的
但是相反對於AI的
AI半導體和雲他們的估值並沒有很高
我個人感覺就是相比較而言並沒有很高
那麼即使在這個市場
可能會出現軟爪路的情況下
其實半導體你說那VD-22倍
那VD-22倍它後面有它的問題
它有個gross
它有那個增長要變緩
然後有那個 margin要變低
但是我們整體看overall sector裡面
比方說你看到Abago
包括你看到Meral
包括你看到一些其他的半導體公司
包括你看到次大兵場
那麼他們的估值相對於還是我覺得偏低的
你可以看到包括Amazon在那個consum...
因為大家有人在定價
就是e-commerce的
e-commerce在缺握中間它定價它會下來
然後再定價廣告數如何下來
包括Google的定價
包括Amazon的定價其實都受到影響
那麼在這個裡面
就是我們認為是
我認為是分裂的
就是整個S&P的估值偏高的同時
那麼有些sector是更高
但是有些sector其實還是有一些機會的
這是我對整個市場的認可
認我認識
那麼說回到宏觀層面的話
我覺得你從經濟程度來講
經濟上數據來說
雖然短期的數據並沒有支持到
那個按馬上會甩退
但是我是認為
Tariff的這個東西是會影響
就是我們回頭對比上一輪的關稅的影響
回頭對比以前關稅對於經濟的影響
就是這個Effective Tariff上升以後
對於關稅對於經濟的影響大概是多少
那麼我們會認為到就是
不管它的現在的Fiddle Code Spending
給市場帶來了多大樂觀的情緒
因為我們剛剛講到了
市場樂觀情緒
你比方說這個30年國債的樂觀情
就是30年國債相反的
就30年國債利率和也有的
和市場走的是一樣
不管它帶來多大的樂觀的情緒
它背後其實有兩個原因
第一個就是我們認為
他們市場認為美國經濟增長
開始變得更好一點
就是更經濟增長
Outlook變得更好一點
第二個Fiddle Code Spending
能夠讓美國經濟變得
就是那個避免下亂著落
或者是更加強硬
但是問題是
你所有的Fiddle Code Spending
需要錢到了Pocket裡面
要到明年3月份
就是退稅政策10月份出來
你的那個真正的錢
要到人的口袋裡要3月份
因為現在你通過的這個
我們叫做退稅的各國獲得
它新的稅收業證字
我們叫就是特朗普表明說
他小費不收稅
包括他有一些
對於個人的稅務的撿命
那這些東西
就是說他真的是那個
到個人的錢包要到明年3月份
在此之前
我們可以認為
我們是裸著面對
就整個市場或者美國經濟
是裸著面對
Factive Table上升11%以上的影響
那麼很難經濟上
沒有任何的衝擊
雖然我們從上一周的數據
就上一周市場又很樂觀
一方面就是我們認為
從Position角度來說
CTA在健康
Wall control
Wall下了以後
Wall control的健康
Respirity也在健康
他們都在健康
同時的話
市場你會看到那個
Consume Confident Index
就是消費信息指數
那麼這個是一個
我們叫做soft data
就是軟數據
它並不是一個硬數據
軟數據看上去還是很不錯
那給市場就說
好
我們出了
關稅
但是我們的軟數據看上去還是很好
那硬數據是不是就不會著落了
這個是市場上一周以來
就上周最後拉動它
還在漲了一個很重要的原因
那麼我本質上
我不太同意這觀點
因為我覺得軟數據
對於經濟的預測
相對來說
過去兩年的trag都比較差
那個中中央有一些原因是
那個政府在消費
就是可能從關稅政府
開始一直在消費
那麼也有原因
就是可能在疫情之後
它的經濟模式裡面
就是soft data影響就沒有
沒有那麼
就prediction都很差
因為之前是負面的
就是那個Consume Confident變差
但是經濟沒有變
經濟沒有變了很差
那麼另外一個原因
其實我覺得soft data到hard data
就是有一個時間
就你關稅出來以後
至少要3到6個月
我們之前講可能要6個月
或者至少要3個月才會有影響
那你現在加的稅的這個影響時間
還沒有到
所以你現在的東西
現在6月份
可能是reboration day之前的這個狀態
而且有一些不supply
有一些強滿
那麼就是
就我們叫做關稅的政策
給市場帶來了波動
包括中國的外貿數就很好
一樣
它是因為可能要加關稅
我先把東西給賣了
因為肯定要加關稅
我先把貨物出海了
所以這個過程中間
它是帶來了一個波動
或者我們就要絞亂了
但是這個市場最後
然後說到了年底
那你該多少
你影響多少
還是會影響得到
那麼那個Tariff和Tax是一樣的
那個影響就是我們覺得1到1.5%
是比較確定
所以25年GDP可能會低於1%
這個我個人感覺
可能會低於1%
因為1到1.5%的影響
那麼這個就是會在一個季度裡面
可能會造成衰退
也可能不會
那麼這個是basic case
就是很有可能在一個季度裡造成衰退
那麼這個影響季度造成衰度
可能是4季度
也更有可能是明年一季度
就是這個從hardy來看
會有這樣的影響
當然了
這個你看上去比較長遠
所以在短期裡面
但市場可以根據情緒隨便吹
根據這個情緒
就是說我們認為美國開始要
明年3月份開始要Fitical Spending了
然後那個市場的現在情緒樂觀的點
是在於美國好像3月份的時候
開始那個
川普不想搞那個
我們叫Osterity
就不想搞財政緊縮
那麼我們美國可能
我們會看到一些對峙的政策
在明年3月份出來
同時的話
我們看到德國在Fitical Spending
對吧
德國很明確的在做財政支出
然後歐洲在做財政支出
包括軍費上面
包括很多投資上面
然後日本在做財政支出
中國也在做
所以我們先認為全球是一輪
Fitical Spending的週期
那麼就我們在Fitical Spending的週期
那很簡單
就回頭看中國2008年
然後它的資產價格會怎麼樣
那全世界就會搞成這個樣子
OK 我覺得是有點道理
那麼但是時間上不太Match
就樂觀情緒有點過早的Pricing了
那麼過早Pricing你可能是對的
但是中間市場是會調整給你看
那這個是我對這個事情的看法
然後最後我覺得說一下那個Trump的Terror
就是那這個是市場
現在沒有很把特朗普要去搞中國
重新搞中國這個東西定價
就是因為我們現在
就是華爾街有一個很有名的華爾街叫Taco
就是Trump always check it out
就是大家覺得他這個政策
反正也是浮動來不動去的 無所謂
那麼但是前兩天確實有很多discussion
就是有很多關於那個International Court
去把就是兩件事情
一件事情Supreme Court ruling
就是這個法院說
特朗普是不能夠隨便replace
Fat Governor agent就是美聯儲的這個官員的
就沒有Jets cost不可以隨便replace
那ok這個我覺得對於市場
是一個很明確的利好
就是說之前其實也是
市場也認為不可能
就是在Court ruling裡面
讓你可以隨便去replace
就是Fat agent就是聯儲的聯儲主席的
所以這個是一個
那麼第二個呢
就是說那個Court of International Trade
去先是說特朗普不能夠block了
特朗普的這個官聖
就是接著呢
他有那個在巡迴法院
就是appear court
就是那個我們叫做那個上訴法院
要重新就是 reinstall
這個Trump的這個tel of
其實在第一次block之後呢
狗們其實就出了一篇報告
我覺得這個挺有道理
反正一個簡單的說法是這樣子
就是即使就是他的
我們叫巡迴法院
或者叫那個
或者叫appear就是那個上訴法院
即使上訴法院不重新reinstall
就重設這個官聖
就是把那個判決給暫停
即使上訴法院不做這個事情
特朗普政府有各種
就作為美國總統
他有各種辦法去加官聖
所以最終的結果是這樣的
他要么就是上訴
要么他能通過其他的section
section 3.1,2.2.2
2.3.2或者102.2這些東西
去重新加官聖
那這個你們可以簡單看一下
這個是公文的一個報告
basically意思就是
如果總統想加官聖
他總是可以加官聖的
法律途徑和那個議會
現在程度上是不能夠block
不能夠讓總統加不上官聖
這個等這個意思
所以就是其實最終還是特朗普的意願
他會不會繼續去加官聖
會不會繼續跟中國這麼搞下去
那有兩種說法
第一種就是特朗普確實
跟中國好像在一些細節裡面又談奔了
那麼這原因可能是由於中國方面
也有可能是美國方面
對吧
中國方面就是中國方面
可能在談判的人
他們覺得談判的人
在一個不該腐軟的時候腐軟
就是說我們現在
Position非常好
就是美國現在馬上貨物的斷貨了
為什麼我們現在要跟美國達成貿易協議
所以其實在中國方面
就是對美對美的割盤
和中國方面
有永遠有對美割盤和對美的硬盤
在每一次跟美國的這個貿易衝突
或者跟美國有矛盾的時候
只要割派犯了錯
他們就會被幹掉
就是從這個官僚體系裡面被幹掉
陰派犯的錯
他們是不會被幹掉
所以整個中國的對美國的這個外交的政策
一定是越來越陰
所以這一次也是一樣
如果說他達成的這個協議
回來之後
各派肯定會被詬病的
說你們太軟弱
我們可以對美國更強硬
美國亡我之心不死
所以中國在執行的
就是造成的結果
就是中國和美國的談判中間
會越來越強硬
然後中國在每一次的這個達成的協議裡面
他遵守一定會很長的肯定的
其實同樣的情況在美國也是一樣
就是特朗普不是一個
一定要把美國經濟搞得很好的人
他本質上他是想要Marco的選票
能夠讓自己在GOP
在那個共和黨裡面更好的立足
所以這兩邊會不停的
就是搞出各種事情
這其實這個觀點
我在上一次達成協議的時候
甚至沒有達成協議的時候
我都講過沒有達成協議的時候
我是覺得他們會莫名其妙
達成一些協議
然後可能會談好
但是這個事情
永遠會扯來扯去扯不完
這個是我對今年
我們叫做今年
我一直講今年時期
是一個tell risk
就是一個尾部風險的年
這是我對今年的一個基本面的判斷
就是這種事情
就是特朗普出來又說要給中國加關稅
然後過兩天又不加
然後又過兩天要給歐洲加關稅
他之前不知道給歐洲加關稅50稅吧
這些事情太正常了
就是這個風險
就是應該在今年被pressing
那我們就是很簡單的看
今年美國市場的估值
你覺得是怎麼樣
我覺得是偏高的
偏高的就低倉穩
然後如果覺得美國有一些set
半導體和那個語音軟件
AI那些東西
估值偏低的
那麼估值偏低就是你有的就是降倉
降倉的部分你就放在那個領域去
所以這個是我對市場的看法
那麼盧寶問到就是
最後關稅政策會不會就是被實施
只要特朗普想就是可以實施
這個所有的那個
你可以把議會和那個法院
他各種官的判決全部一個腦子
全部無視掉
影響不了
他有各種各樣其他辦法
可以繞過去的
然後第二個就是特朗普
有沒有意願跟就是關稅繼續搞下去
因為繼續搞下去
能夠取悅馬卡
他一定會就是至少在刑事上
一定會來來回回搞
就這個是我對於那個市場的兩樣看法
那麼短期裡面
soft data
我覺得這個沒有那麼重要
更加重要的數據是hard data
hard data就是能放配合
in-employment
能放配合肯定更加重要一點吧
就比方說能放配合
那麼最後說一下
因為我剛剛講到了個股的這個估值
那我估值
那我覺得我剛剛講了那個Mega 7
我沒有講Mega 7
我講的是四個名場
不是沒有講Mega 7的
最中間有很重要的就是Tesla
Tesla我覺得他當然沒走完
我曾經講過一個
就是說什麼時候可以去買Tesla
我對Tesla是一直是
我是一個非常忠實的特斯拉粉
然後我去年很多的吹著
穿錢都跑特斯拉賺的錢
然後最後我跑掉了
我也沒進去
對吧 我一直講220塊錢要殺進去
到了220我又沒有買
但是Tesla為什麼呢
我一直在講特斯拉是什麼樣的一個時間
是我覺得是一個可能可以樂觀的
就是一路罵死後回到Tesla
是個事情已經發生了
但是我找總盤說是為什麼
我現在還沒有想去健康特斯拉
第一個整個acquity的估值
S&P估值過高
如果他殺估值的話
那些就是
適夢率的公司會殺得比較慘
就是你十大十的向你VDN也會殺
但是畢竟盈利放在那裏
就是包括各種
MVL盈利放在那裏
然後那個斯達銀廠
那個Avago盈利都放著
那個特斯拉估值比較高
他有很多的適夢率在裏面
所以他如果殺估值會殺得比較慘
第二個特斯拉的那個
我覺得他的當倫沒走完
450塊錢對應的是
他今年20%的增長
給市場預期要20%的增長
給市場預期6月份Robotaxi出來
那麼第一個已經不可能了
就是說我們會看到中國的電車
已經競爭到內捲到一個極致了
這個特斯拉的中國風格也佔20%
那這個他硬生生的要跟他們
這些富裕產能50%的這個車廠們
就是中國車廠歐歐歐
富裕產能50%
然後歐歐歐大家就捲死
那這種情況下面你要去跟他PK的
中國的產能還沒有PK到歐洲和美國去
但是會不會有一些產能
比如說通過我們之前講的這個形勢
包括領配件
包括各方面都是會PK到境外去的
所以這個對整個境外的影響
就是至少在中國層面
對S特斯拉業績影響是很大的
然後特斯拉那個英文一路馬斯的戰錯隊
然後使得自己的中式買家
中式買家全是左派
買電車的沒有右派
馬卡就開著小皮卡
沒人開那個特斯拉的
所以在美國的銷量和歐洲的銷量
會不會受到影響
就一定會受到影響
那個第二個就是特斯拉的車
其實對於Long Run Incher Street影響
就是很敏感
這個長期的利率
長期利率代表著美國
美國買車都是利用車袋的
所以美國買車用車袋的話
你長期利率Long Run Incher Street上去的時候
車的銷量就是一定會受到影響
就是哪怕沒有這些政治因素
沒有那個中國內卷影響
它也是會影響
所以特斯拉我覺得今年要消化掉
從正20%到-10%的這樣一個Gross
這個數據是要消化掉的
現在沒有消化 我覺得
現在有可能有一點消化
但是消化的方法是
他們覺得Robotaxi會頂上了
Robotaxi6月份可能會出來
但是我覺得頂不上
從恩寧程度上頂不上
或者是因為他給他講了一個故事
但是故事這個東西
就是講完以後
他就不能再支持了
市場對於銀利
對於公司股價也支持
是只要這個銀利在
他永遠能支持
但是故事的影響是這故事講完
你得講下一個故事
就是How we find
沒有那麼快tap out的明年
今年年底的明年
所以我是感覺
就是特斯拉的downround
沒有完全走完
這是一個我非常喜歡的公司
而且我一直關注
我會中藏買的公司
但是我現在不會中藏買
我這我對特斯拉一個評價
然後我覺得今天
我覺得Q&A
大家問一下問題
看有什麼問題
我先